clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci à toi
salut romain ça va alors tes vacances
c'était comme en super sympa du mystery
6-6-6 ouais j'ai vu sa valeur hyper beau
non g et toi alors non voilà non non moi
je suis parti je suis resté à paris j'ai
fait une coloscopie par contre tu vas
voir les photos ci s'y attends je te
montrerai regarde regarde tu as vu ça tu
as vu la couleur de cette muqueuse la
ceiba nick auteur nous et se regardent
sûrement mais c'est quoi ce truc là à
droite
attend qu est-ce que c'est une
coccinelle non
une coccinelle donc on peut rencontrer
une coccinelle pendant une coloscopie
betabondieu d'entre eux un animal dans
un être humain d'accord ok admettons
soyons professional étudions la question
à l'occasion d'une coloscopie un médecin
a effectivement découvert une harmonia
axyridis c'est à dire une coccinelle
asiatique qui prolifèrent en europe et
aux états unis depuis la fin des années
80 et cette coccinelle il l'a découverte
dans le col ou transverses d'un patient
de 59 ans voilà le cas a été documentée
dans la littérature scientifique grâce à
un article publié en 2019 et j'en
profite pour remercier pierre garner qui
a porté cet article à ma connaissance
pierre garner qui écrit tout un tas de
truc absolument passionnant dans son
blog stein stein funky things je vous
met à lire dans la description abonne
toi d'iran
si vous êtes comme moi arriver à ce
stade vous est assailli de questions
comment la coccinelle at elle pu se
retrouver là at elle survécu
thomas dutronc sont ils des triplés
comme je voulais en avoir le coeur net
j'ai contacté l'un des auteurs de
l'article en question le docteur
vaisselle pam qui est le directeur du
service de gastro entérologie de
l'université du missouri il m'a répondu
il est très sympa comme vous pouvez le
voir et il m'a précisé deux trois trucs
comment s est retrouvé la dame son
hypothèse est la suivante la coccinelle
a été chargé dé d'une manière ou d'une
autre soient elles a été avalé par
accident soit elle est en très belle
même pendant le sommeil du patient alors
si des hypothèses dont il parle déjà
d'un article et le dr thanh m'a confirmé
que c'est de la pure spéculation
attention il m'a quand même repréciser
que en andorre le nez et la bouche qui
sont des accès direct au système
digestif il reste complètement ouvert
donc elle a très bien pu passer par là
et comme il est super pro il en a
profité pour éliminer la russe comme
porte d'entrée et potentiels étant donné
que je le cite la musique a souvent en
période d'inactivité
donc d'une manière ou d'une autre elle
est rentrée par le haut elle s'est
retrouvée dans l'estomac et comme avant
de faire du coloscopie il faut voir
plusieurs litres de liquide spécial pour
bien nettoyer la tuyauterie oui on parle
d'une laxatifs partie en gros le torrent
a très bien pu entraîner la bestiole
jusque dans le côlon ça fait un sacré
voyage mais c'est plausible bon et s
qu'elle était vivante quand il l'a
trouvé hélas le médecin va confirmer ce
que je craignais contrairement à ce
qu'une certaine presse sans scrupule a
affirmé à l'époque le petit animal n'a
pas assuré
[Musique]
autant en admettant même qu'elle est
supporté le bas dans les sucs digestifs
de l'estomac
[Musique]
puis le tsunami de chiasse il a amené
jusque là il ya quand même un autre
problème les insectes ils ont besoin
d'oxygène pour vivre et de l'oxygène ok
il y en a dans les intestins mais il y
en a de moins en moins au fur et à
mesure qu'on se rapproche de la sortie
parce qu'il est consommé par les
bactéries qu'on a toutes et tous dans le
tube digestif et qui nous aident à
digérer justement et il se trouve que
ces matériaux on a littéralement 100
millions de fois plus dans le côlon que
dans l'estomac donc arriver au niveau du
côlon transverses autant vous dire
qu'ils fassent plus beaucoup d'oxygène
et que l'atmosphère est très peu
respirable vu qu'elle est
essentiellement composé de paix
je vous déconseille de faire
l'expérience chez vous croyez moi sur
tarn voilà pour la réponse aux questions
comment est ce qu'elle est arrivée là et
est-ce qui est là si on est tu par
contre thomas dutronc désolé mais le
mystère reste entier le dr thanh mais a
insisté sur le fait que à sa
connaissance c'était le premier cas
documenté de coccinelles retrouver dans
un col haut mais qu'il y avait quand
même des cas similaires j'ai donc décidé
de poursuivre mon enquête est
effectivement en cherchant un peu j'ai
trouvé d'autres histoires du même genre
mais avec des protagonistes différents
tomes cet animal par exemple on a
retrouvé encore une fois dans un
colloque transverses celui d'une femme
de 51 ans un cafard accapare identifient
comme une plate et la germanique à
lattes germanique
qui avait la particularité d'avoir une
espèce de gelée verte et du land plan
des pattes ils sont armés la patiente
qui avait des antécédents psychiatriques
a nié avoir avalé volontairement et les
médecins en ont déduit qu'elle avait
ingéré accidentellement en mangeant de
la gelée
la gelée verte et malgré sa réputation
d'être incroyable le cafard était lui
aussi décédé sans pour les mêmes raisons
que la coccinelle oui parce que
contrairement à ce qu'on pense un cafard
aussi ça a besoin d'oxygène pour
en poursuivant mes recherches j'ai
découvert aussi des cas impliquant des
hyménoptères dans des conditions assez
similaires pour faire progresser un
petit peu l'enquète on va s'attarder sur
le cas de cette fourmi retrouver dans le
col ou descends dans cette fois d'un
homme de 66 ans dans le côlon
descendants donc un peu plus loin que
les précédents
bien joué les championnes dans l'article
qu'ils ont publiées sur ce cas les
médecins ont précisé que deux jours
avant de faire sa coloscopie le patient
avait pique-niqué dans un parc et qu'il
avait je cite consommé plusieurs
assiette de salade de pommes de terre et
des ailes de poulet qui offrait
semblablement servi de vecteur inanimé à
la cour me malchanceux la thèse de
l'accident donc fois pour expliquer à la
fois la présence est comme vous entendez
la mort de cet insecte dans un colon du
rein avec quand même un élément
supplémentaire concernant la cause du
décès l'article précise qu'il est
possible que l'acide chlorhydrique qu'on
va naturellement dans notre estomac et
et causé des dégâts importants à
l'exosquelette de la fourmi entraînant
sa mort alors si on veut synthétiser un
petit peu tout ça on peut retenir une
chose les animant qu'on avale vivant ne
le reste pas longtemps mais j'ai quand
même lu que si on avale une huître
semble à mâcher elle pourra survivre
jusqu'à deux heures et demie dans notre
estomac
donc il reste malgré tout un
environnement assez peu propice à
l'épanouissement personnel
et de toute façon comme on l'a vu après
plus on descend en noir l'atmosphère est
bien attention là on parle d'insectes et
de mollusques adultes mais si on parle
de larmes là c'est pas la même chose
parce qu'elles sont capables de survivre
à des conditions extrêmes est ce que
vous vous souvenez du ténia du renard je
vous avais parlé le site et voilà
typiquement ce qu'on a mal c est d eux
des kings oxus multilocularis
est inverse
c'est ce qu'ils ont la capacité de
résister à l'acidité gastrique du coup
ils vont se loger plus loin jusque dans
l'intestin grêle dans les larves se
développent et puis après elle migre
jusque dans le foie essentiellement est
arrivée sur place elle se fabrique des
petits kystes bien vrai et elle
s'installe nos voiliers il y en a qui
survivent à l'estomac comme le ténia
tout pour continuer
et comme plein d'autres vers aussi comme
les autres sur les ascaris coup la
touffe du foie voilà je vais pas rentrer
dans les détails parce que j'en vois
deux ou trois qu'on changeait de couleur
à mais sachez que le monde à bord une
souris morte dans le tri par sa porte à
conséquence par contre avoir des animaux
vivants à l'intérieur de soi c'est plus
embêtant les parasites intestinaux par
exemple c'est un ouf la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on peut y échapper en
respectant deux trois règles assez
simples à savoir toujours bien laver ce
qu'on mange bien cuire ses aliments et
notamment sa viande boire de l'eau du
robinet ou en bouteille mais éviter tout
ce qui est rivières ruisseaux lacs
piscine caniveau
globalement bon laver régulièrement chez
soi la base et traiter régulièrement ces
animaux de compagnie si on en a pas ce
qu'ils peuvent avoir des espèces de
petits sous locataire ça c'est si on est
en france métropolitaine si on est dans
des endroits un petit peu plus exotiques
il ya d'autres précautions
supplémentaires à prendre on en a déjà
parlé d'ailleurs dans une vidéo je vous
remets le violent dans le respect et
peut-être qu'on reparlera de parasites
un de ces jours et alors si ça vous
intéresse là bas il ya aussi d'autres
situations dans lesquelles on peut
retrouver un animal vivant ou là des
aliments vivants à l'intérieur du corps
d'un être humain je veux vous parler des
migac une milhazes c'est un mot un peu
pompeux pour décrire une réalité un
chouïa moins de l'amour vous allez voir
à savoir que votre corps héberge et
l'art de diptères
que les bouches notre ans du dedans en
fête ou des moustiques alors il ya
plusieurs types de médias par exemple
certaines l'ias intestinale dans
lesquelles s'est fatalement puis elle
bouche lorsqu'il a produit à l'intérieur
c'est plus que vous avez avalé ces oeufs
ou ses larmes oui mais pourquoi vous
faites ça aussi bon je vais donner un
exemple très concret qui va sûrement
parler aux amateurs de fromages de
caractère est ce que vous connaissez le
cas joubert
c'est un fromage un peu particulier
c'est khaled qui triment l'ange rien c
est un fromage qui est élaboré notamment
grâce aux asticots qui se développent
dans des asticots qui ne sont rien
d'autre que des larves de mouches des
mouches du fromage comme on les appelle
des pioches il a quasi donc les larmes
ont la particularité de résister à
l'acidité de l'estomac et de survivre
dans l'intestin
[Musique]
alors vous allez me dire comme
d'habitude y en a que pour l'intestin
mici et bien détrompez-vous parce que
les bases sont pas du tout la chasse
gardée de cet organe facétieux alors non
on a vraiment pour tout le monde à
chacun samia à tel point que vous
pourriez même dire c'est un miyazaki ça
encore
et ça ça prête bien barré les amateurs
d'animer et de parasites
un peu déçu parce que les bouches elles
peuvent aussi décider de prendre sous la
peau par exemple et du coup les larves
pour pouvoir bien se développer elle
s'aménage des furoncles ou des abcès
voilà sous notre co comme ça elles
peuvent aussi décider d'aller
s'installer dans d'autres organes comme
les yeux le nez les oreilles ou les
organes génitaux et c'est beaucoup plus
rare genre c'est vraiment très rare mais
du coup c'est aussi beaucoup plus grave
les larves maintenant aussi aller
s'installer dans le cerveau ou les
poumons alors on va calmer le jeu tout
de suite là on parle de cas vraiment
exceptionnel soit parce que ça concerne
des régions tropicales fréquentes
vraiment pas tous les jours soit parce
que avant que les larmes atteignent les
organes en question est normalement ils
se passent deux trois trucs qui attire
l'attention des gens donc mon petit
conseil le jour donne parce que c'est
pas la première fois quand vous sentez
qu'il ya quelque chose qui va pas à
boutons un peu gros qui veut pas partir
un truc qui gonfle qui devient rouge qui
chauffe qui grattent des troubles
digestifs qui veulent pas s'arrêter etc
etc aller chez le médecin pareil si vous
avez une baisse d'audition brutale avec
des petits bruits parasites ce qui
pourrait très bien porter une horde de
petits bruits base vous pensiez
peut-être que c'était des légendes
urbaines mais non en fait on peut
vraiment trouver des bestioles vivante
dans les oreilles des gens ça par
exemple c'est une araignée qui a été
dénichée dans un conduit auditif par un
oral à tout mais on a aussi d'autres cas
comme une tique chez un enfant de 9 ans
une punaise c'est un homme de 63 ans ou
encore des cas par des fourmis des
mouches des papillons des puces des
pince oreilles ou des scarabées et j'en
passe donc là c'est pareil redoutent
attendait pas tant à et alors dernière
petite chose et après je vous laisse
prendre votre rendez vous sur d'autoliv
là on a parlé de cas où des animaux il
était entré dans le corps n'a de façon
accidentelle mais ça n'est pas toujours
comme ça que ça se passe des chirurgiens
du wisconsin ont récemment rapporté dans
une publication avoir retiré un axe
haulotte vivant de l'abdomen d'un homme
de 66 ans insolite non c'est faux j'ai
inventé cette histoire de toutes pièces
pas pour gouverner non bien sûr je vous
respecte beaucoup trop haut pour ça mais
pour vous rappeler qu'il faut pas croire
tout ce qu'on vous raconte quand même
pour rester dans la thématique qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui croire et faire
tourner des informations non vérifiées
comme ça ça a donné naissance à une
légende urbaine concernant une pratique
sexuelle qu'on appelle le germyn
le gervais dean consistant à
s'introduire une gerbille vivant dans le
rectum
je crois que maintenant vous savez à la
nasa les gens d'aller partie d'une
fausse dépêche mon agence de presse
américaine la dunette presse
internationale à laquelle tout le monde
a cru
et pas seulement aux états unis
d'ailleurs parce qu'elle est arrivée
jusqu'en france sous la forme d'une
fausse dépêche de l afp l' agence
france-presse dans laquelle la gerbille
était devenu un hamster et qui a été lu
en direct à la radio la dépêche de l afp
qui est un comme des pêches très
sérieuse j'ai poussé un tube en carton
dans son rectum et j'ai glissé radote
notre hamster à l'intérieur at il
expliqué comme d'habitude mon partenaire
kiki à cri armageddon pour indiquer
qu'il en avait assez la légende elle a
tellement bien fait qu'on s'est mis à
raconter un petit peu n'importe quoi
genre par exemple que richard geere
était adepte du jardin ligne et qu'ils
avaient dû être hospitalisés pour qu'on
lui retire aux rongeurs du
le jir building ça n'existe pas alors je
dis pas qu'il n'ya pas quelqu'un quelque
part qui a essayé un jour c'est probable
que six en tout cas c'est pas une
pratique avec des milliers d'adeptes qui
donc c'est pas un truc est a priori
relais chargeur ne fait pas ça en tout
cas a priori parce que bon on va
l'histoire elle a été démentie mais moi
oui charge c'est parce qu'ils te soirée
enfin si je sais d'ailleurs il fait ce
qu'il veut et ça m'emmerde du coup un
petit point rapide parce qu'il en a déjà
parlé plusieurs fois ici mais
apparemment le message n'est pas passé
c'est introduire des objets non prévu à
cet effet dans les orifices naturels
cela peut présenter des risques
s'introduire des animaux vivants encore
plus si on cherche un petit peu on
trouve facilement des cas documentés qui
implique des envies ou des poissons
rouges etc alors déjà l'animal et vous a
rien demandé foutez lui la paix ensuite
ils peuvent vous blesser quand ça se
sent pris au piège en face on roule ça
peut être hyper v ner et enfin on en a
déjà parlé plusieurs fois je vous
rappelle ce que vous avez dit dans la
vidéo sur les pires conseils santé à
corps étrangers qui restent coincés dans
l'organisme ça peut donner des
infections et ça peut très mal fini donc
pour les uns trop mission avisé
récréative je rappelle les règles d'or
le consentement d'abord des partenaires
et de ce qui va être introduit
j'en profite pour rappeler qu'un animal
n'est pas un objet et que comme il peut
pas exprimer sans consentement dans le
doute on s'abstient l'hygiène ensuite
l'introduction de matières qui pourrait
laisser des fragments et se dégrader in
situ c'est à proscrire le risque étant
l'infection à midi la voir le choc
septique qui peut entraîner un décès
définitive la sécu rité on introduit
dans son corps que des accessoires prévu
à cet effet et profilé en conséquence
afin d'éviter qu'ils le restent coincés
et pour finir la bienveillance on ne
juge pas les pratiques des uns et des
autres chacune et chacun fait ce qu'il
veut de son corps voilà des essais c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici
là prenez soin de vous et prenez soin
des autres mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]